will and his wife got coronavirus they
had gotten tested right yeah they did
they didn't get the result well when did
you get the test back
but the coronavirus wasn't it like
homeless when you guys were free and
clear of it it was eight days after she
took the test Wow yeah it was craziness
and then again like you said you know
our whole family had it but my wife is
the only one that actually went and got
a test so all the numbers are kind of
meaningless out there I think way more
people have it then they're claiming you
know these government statistics what
was your wife's experience with the
corona virus what was it like to
actually have it well I think we were
pretty lucky conserve is pretty low
grade which is still rough so we both
had low-grade fevers we both just kind
of felt awful we ended up having a lot
of like stomach issues which some people
have some people don't she had a bad
cough she had a hacking cough it's still
hasn't quite gone away but we didn't
have any of the respiratory issues thank
God that you know people are really
struggling with was she vomiting a lot
she was vomiting yes she had there was a
couple days there where she was in real
bad shape she couldn't hold anything
down that's why I don't want to get it I
haven't vomited since college and I'm
really I have a phobia about vomiting I
do not want to bomb it well that doesn't
seem to happen to everybody the stomach
thing doesn't you know if that's a weird
thing about this it's it's just that you
you'll think you're over it and then
like it just lingers like you can
relapse and like go back to feeling like
complete [ __ ] again did the kids get it
yeah I think my son had it
luckily for kids it doesn't seem to be
as strong he had it for like he had a
fever for like a night but you know poor
kids eight years old he was scared out
of his mind he's seen all this craziness
know the news and he thinks you know
something's gonna happen to him and then
my daughter had it for I don't know a
few hours she went to bed with a fever
kind of woke up fine
Will's like Superman he got over it like
in a day or yeah yeah
hey my stomach a little upset yeah it
was for the for my wife and I it was
rough for two weeks and then you got to
deal with the kids on top all that did
you shed a lot yes it was
yes [ __ ] was definitely an issue a
potato I was trying to eat cuz yeah I
mean I don't know ever that upset kind
of upset stomach where you're you don't
know if you're hungry or you're sick to
your stomach it's hard to tell that
disgusting [ __ ] where like could
make this spray on the back of a toilet
and stuff at the beginning of it yeah
there was definitely like my it was
spray [ __ ] oh that's good disgusting
well I'm glad you're feeling better and
I'm glad your wife's feeling better
thank you
you